in order to try to get as many
sourdoughs as possible identified in the
world I am on a quest for sourdough for
the moment we host 107 starters from
more or less 20 countries and so we
ended up with 17 sourdoughs from 17
bakeries in italy a 40 41 42 from
hungaria
the 64 was an old lady in china it's
it's our dose with a story where I know
the people behind like 79 is from Josie
Baker in San Francisco 104 106 and 107
go back to the Klondike Gold Rush every
library as a librarian well it happens
that in this sourdough library I'm
decided a librarian when an idea like a
sourdough library pops up and you are
able to to do it from from from scratch
well it's it's my baby that's why I grew
so much into it with this one I have a
very special relationship because it was
the very first sourdough starter we had
this was my very first sourdough I saw
in my life and so I started refreshing
it and I I had to bake with it I
immediately got interested by this NGO
that I'd never seen before and being a
baker you want to know more about but
what's going on in there and then you
start feeding it and you see it bubbling
and it's a life it's like a pet in the
90s many people had this little
Tamagotchi the the little thing that you
had to feed and now if you killed it
it was okay because you could just reset
the whole thing and start all over well
here not we have living sourdoughs
they are bubbly every two months we open
the jars and we feed the sourdough with
their original flour following the
original recipe and that guarantees that
they are not changing the fact that we
decided to create this library is first
of all to preserve its biodiversity
if tomorrow someone who has a sourdough
that maybe he or she parroted from its
father or grandmother or whatever and if
he or she would stop cultivating that
sourdough
well it's lost in English we use the
word sourdough but in many cultures
there is no link to sourness the French
ones they say lava the Italians they use
a veto naturally which means natural
yeast but the most beautiful description
for a sourdough is the Spanish word masa
Madre which is the mother dough when a
daughter in the past was going to get
married
she received a piece of the mother dough
with her in order to feed her family
which sourdoughs is back on the map
today there is a revival many people
rediscover again sourdough and that's
the beauty sourdough bread is so much
better for human kind then then just
regular bread that is fermented with
yeast I think that every bread has
something good but sourdough just brings
it to another level
you